おおー
クラロワやってる人キャプテン優弥って
いうクランにはいって
嫌です
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんゲーセンとかよく行きますか？
あのゲーセンによくあるあれわかりますか？
この丸いドーム型になってって
なんかお菓子とかキーホルダーとか
なんかよくわかんないすけど
なんかお菓子とかフィギアとか
なんかチロルチョコを
こうやってね　こうなってるのがあって
ずっとこうやって動いてて
いーーーーーーーーーち
に
つって落として
こうなんか……
（伝えたいけど言葉がでない）
あああああああああああああああああああああああ
今ので伝わったらいいんですけども
なんかその100円でこういうなんか
取れるUFOキャッチャーの
なんかドーム版みたいなやつ
あるじゃないですか
あん中で多分皆さん見たこと
あると思うんですけども
ちょっと持ってきます
ふぅーーーーーー
はじめん必殺☆開封の舞
（あぁ中身が心配になってきた）
え、待ってやばい
スーーーー
そんなファイルの破け方ありますか
ビリビリビリビリ
ドンッドンッドンッドンッ
グシャ
ヤベ！ヤベ
ヤベーヤベ
トントントン
これ多分ゲーセンで見たことある人
多いと思うんですけど
（苦笑い）
なんかこういうやつね
なんかゲーセンでよくないですか
UFOキャッチャーとかの ハズレんとこに
よくあると思うんですけど
こういうなんか…
いわゆる…
宝石っぽいヤツっスね!!
まぁこうやってなんか100円でこうやってね
すくった分全部あげますよ
みたいな感じだと思うんですけど
それを今回ちょっとあのー
できるだけ買ってみました
買い過ぎちゃった
はい、というわけで
多分4万円分ぐらいあの宝石すくい
あのUFOキャッチャーの
ハズレの方の宝石買ってみました
いやーあの本当に純粋に綺麗だなーと
思って買ってみたんですよ
だって綺麗じゃん
めっちゃ綺麗だよ
いやーまじで綺麗ですね
はい、というわけで
えー男のお前がなに宝石集めてんだよ
きもっ
って言われるかもしれないんですけども
いいんです
というわけでちょっと俺買ったのにも
ちゃんと理由がありまして
お部屋を綺麗に
彩りたいんですよ
物が少ないことだけが
僕は最近美しいじゃないな
みたいなことを思いまして
なんかやっぱ物がないとやっぱ
綺麗なんですけども
オシャレとはまた違うんですよね
ものがあってからこそのオシャレっていう
ものに僕は気づき始めたので
もう僕はこのうまい棒をたくさん見ても
あの一種のオシャレだと思っております
そこで今回4万円分の宝石を使って
何をしようかといいますと
お家で最も汚そうな場所
どこだと思いますか？
そう！Toilet
トイレをこの4万円分の宝石で照らすと
うわああああああああああ
あっ死んだと思った
多分なんですけど世界で一番
綺麗で美しくかわいい
ビューティフルキュートトイレに
なると僕は思うんですよ
だってトイレ入るたびに
宝石に囲まれるんですよ
もうそんな幸せの気持ちで
あの…
なにやれ…出したり…出したり
出すことしかないんですけど
なんかすごいハッピーな気持ちで
オシャレなトイレになれるんじゃないかと思いまして
大量の宝石箱置いていこうと思います
調べたところ1個約2kgぐらいなんで
40kg分の宝石をトイレでこう散りばめて
うちのトイレを使用する方の
お声を聞いてみたいと思います
では行こう‼︎‼︎
というわけでトイレです
はい
なんもねぇ〜
ってかトイレットペーパー買いすぎなんだよな
まだここにもあるし
いやびっくりするぐらいなんにもないんですよね
誰だよこれ置いたの⁉︎
ただ問題はこの数でトイレがどれくらい
いっぱいになるかなんすよね
うわっあっ
なにないなに
だれだれだれ
何が起きたの今
ってか何でここにLUXが置いてあんだよ
だれかｗ
誰かトイレの水で洗髪したんかな？
痛っ！痛っ待って痛た
待ってやばい問題だ
問題が発生したぞ
おい！問題が発生したぞ
痛い
あぁはっはっはっはっ
まぁ基本床だけなんですけども
えーっというわけで宝石40kgに
埋まってしまったトイレ
いやこんだけ綺麗だと
さすがにみんなテンション
上がるんでないでしょうか
でもね僕も今
座ってて気づいたんだけど
痛いんですよ
ダイヤモンドのチクチクの部分が
超足に刺さってて
結構笑えない痛みなんでぇ
皆んな多分ね綺麗とは思いつつも
最初に出る言葉は多分
痛い
痛い痛いって言うと思います
美しものには棘がある
待って本当に笑えない痛みなんで
ちょっと皆んな来るのを待ちましょう
では
たなっち）痛ていてて
やふへゐ先生）いだいだいだい